martha stewart you are gonna
teach how to gift wrap now i'm not gonna
lie
i'm more like the kooky person in the
kitchen
bringing the comedy and i can't believe
i'm about to get a lesson
from you in gift wrapping which is not a
strong suit for me
i am so excited i'm going to pay
attention like nobody's business
let's get wrapping what are we wrapping
today
start with a small present and a
rectangular box is a very nice thing to
start with
and if there's a lot of um floater on
the box itself
you might want to double up on your
paper this is a thin paper that i'm
using this beautiful
greenish blue paper so i'm starting
with a piece of paper that's much longer
than the box but
about two inches wider than the box
and then i always fold over my ends like
this and then
roll the box very carefully
on this rectangle of paper pulling it
taut
because you want to see nose
and you don't want any wrinkles and you
want it really really
tight what about the wrinkles in my face
okay are you getting it done and then
you have double stick tape there
yep wait what did you do with the ends
like hospital corners tuck in the ends
and then then put some double stick tape
is that this and pull it up like that
okay oh my gosh martha i've never done
hospital corners and then and then
did you like kind of fold it like
see i feel in the ends looks like this
uh-huh and nice and nice and
neat want to be very neat oh no i've
done something wrong
a story in this december issue of the
magazine on
beautiful dresden ornaments
these were made about 200 years ago in
dresden germany
and they had just improved a stamping
machine
that was able to cut out beautiful
objects like this and stamp them
and they made them out of gold and
silver foil paper
and now they come in all colors and
again use your double stick tape
and apply these beautiful dresdens
just look up dresdens on the internet
and you'll find fabulous
sources for these and look just one star
makes this
a beautiful present i'm gonna just
embellish
and they come these were some little
ornaments so i'm just gonna cover up a
little
spot that looks like it's a hanger
do you have dresdens there with you
like them i love them i don't know if
you're going to like what i'm doing to
them but i love
them you know that's your personal
taste and uh and i'm sure it's good your
taste
so here's my my present and this is
going right
into the mail and be sent to you because
you ate up your
other box i'm sending this off to you
okay i
i don't want you to see the back because
it's really bad but oh
hold on okay
what do you think for some reason i just
you
you went off it's good right
i can't see it yet wait wait oh you
would be so
proud gosh if you hold it a certain way
oh oh god the dresden
don't lose the dresdens i'm so pretty i
shan't
lose the dresden perfect
so listen drew uh when all of this is
over
i'm coming to your studio to see all my
and
we're gonna do a really complicated
project okay
i would love if you would come here so
much you just gave me 20 21 goals
all the way thank you martha stewart
martha don't forget to catch me tonight
on martha knows best on
[Music]
hgtv